[Música]
estamos aquí en el estudio con ramón
ramón chicharrón como esta
bienvenido a canadá en las américas en
realidad de radio canadá internacional
cómo van las cosas lanzando un nuevo
disco entonces si es más un ep de cinco
canciones en donde voy a presentar un
nuevo material el último material que
fue el álbum web page
ese otro material formas afrocolombiano
en este lado voy a mostrar otro lado de
colombia es la champeta la champeta es
un poco no es un poco más mucha
influencia africana mucha influencia del
psuv jus
y es un ritmo caribeño este toca mucho
en barranquilla cartagena santa marta
y no no es como la comes un poco
diferente pero se baila igual
originalmente usted nació en colombia en
qué región de colombiana de medellín en
medellín
entonces usted fue descubriendo estos
estos ritmos estando ya que en montreal
lo que es para celular como hizo para
descubrir este tipo esta otra parte de
la de la música colombiana existe porque
si uno realmente descubre más la cultura
de su país cuando está afuera no conozco
exterior se pone a analizar la riqueza
cultural que tiene su país la riqueza
musical
entonces me atrajo mucho también este
estos ritmos porque viendo toda la
influencia africana montreal
hay mucho el ritmo del sucu si llovía
pero comparándolo con la champeta en
colombia es muy parecido demasiado
parecido
viene directamente de áfrica entonces
guau me puse a analizar esos ritmos son
super pegajosos es increíble poder
ponerlo realmente analizar y hacer algo
d
[Música]
a day
y este álbum es pepe merecumbé significa
algo la palabra merecumbé si viene de
pacho galán que fue el que inventó los
años 50 viene de los de la cumbia ambas
donde se reunían la gente ya se da
fiestas y hacían improvisaciones en sus
cantos en donde como hablaban de su día
a día
en estas en estas fiestas bailando el
merecumbé es un ritmo de merengue
colombiano no es merengue dominicano
sino bien merengue también colombiano es
un merengue que es un poco combinado con
cumbia también esto una mezcla que se
creó en estos años por galán ayudante
usted dice que ustedes montreal ence de
corazón nació en colombia pero viven en
montreal hace varios años ya de qué
manera en montreal se siente en su
música se escucha en la música que está
presentando ahora claro obviamente la
una de las razones por las cuales me
vine montreal fue porque llegué un
verano acá y con todos los festivales
me quedé loco me enamoré de tener tanta
posibilidad de ver tantos tantas
influencias musicales en un mismo lugar
un festival internacional de jazz y
otros después de festivales alrededor de
los meses de verano sí exacto marca
estival noches de africano y de áfrica
que tiene la cantidad de grupos super
buenos cada año entonces
poder poder tocar música aquí colombiana
con músicos de otras culturas es le
ofrece obviamente un color muy
interesante a la música
qué planes tiene para él para el disco
porque bueno lo presenta este mes el mes
de mayo el 24 de mayo aquí en la ciudad
de montreal pero qué planes tiene usted
quiere volver a colombia con esta música
quiere viajar por otros lados a donde
quiera llevarla tuve la oportunidad de
ir el año pasado a colombia y presentar
el álbum que en algún pasado el web page
y fue un gran un gran reto no porque era
como la primera vez como colombiana
tocando música colombiana en colombia
porque siempre tocaba música colombiana
en el exterior aquí y lo tomaron con
mucha aceptación la gente
toqué medellín y en santa marta los dos
lugares estaba lleno estaba en el lugar
y la gente estaba cantando las canciones
mismos y no las conocidas no se ponían a
este bailando y la aceptaron súper bien
entonces quedé muy contento entonces el
plan es como volver a colombia y volver
a presentar este nuevo material
el próximo invierno
sí
qué
[Música]
ahora este nuevo material usted lo
compuso lo cree o no en colombia ni en
montreal sino en costa rica como pues
aventura teatral o varios varios ya
varios años es en este nuevo material y
había compuesto cosas aquí pero decidí
que necesita como un lugar donde tuviera
con una inspiración del lado de la
naturaleza costa rica siempre ha tenido
como ese
es el lado de la preservación natural de
que son super conscientes con la
naturaleza
me fui mi internet
en la selva en la cabaña metido metido
en la selva y pude organizar mi estudio
y comencé a grabar pero con la que me
llevé la sorpresa de que siempre había
demasiado ruido tanto de los modos de
los monos y los mono y los grillos los
sonidos constantes de los grillos que no
para entonces yo veía como en mi
computadora y en el porque es un
micrófono condensador eso capta todo
siempre estás en esas ese en el en el
background común detrás de la grabación
siempre está ese sonido de los grillos y
todo entonces cuando vine aquí a editar
las canciones me di cuenta que estaba
súper presente y decidí dejarlo decidí
dejar esa ese sonido de los grillos y
antes de subir el volumen y el sonido de
los monos también hay una canción muy
particular que se llama los monos
y es que habla un poco de
me inspiré porque yo abría la ventana y
veía los monos adictos los días estaban
todos los días venían ahí y estaban
haciendo una bulla increíble entonces me
inspiró a componer esa canción como que
los monos nos hablan a nosotros que nos
dicen oye qué está pasando porque no
están tomando la casa y justamente usted
también se inspira de esta región de
costa rica y de también la selva
colombiana porque no y tiene un mensaje
ecologista un mensaje de concientización
cuéntenos un poco cuál es el mensaje que
trae él además de la fiesta y además del
buen sonido y las cintas influencias
históricas de la música colombiana cuál
es el mensaje más allá de esos mensajes
más más social digamos así como la
importancia de reconectar nos nuevamente
con la con el medio natural
con el medio ambiente
y de observar todo desde un punto más
exterior como si nos pudiéramos
transportar al espacio y ver el planeta
que está disfrutando y ver que todo lo
que está pasando es las cosas que
nosotros nos creamos nosotros mismos
pero que si instalamos todos los bosques
estaremos en el agua el oxígeno todo lo
que necesitamos todo lo básico que
necesitamos para vivir no va a estar ahí
entonces como que bueno te toca tomar el
tiempo de sentarnos a meditar y ver cómo
que que está que estamos realmente bien
estamos en un tren que va contra un muro
que se va a chocar y hasta que no se
choque no vamos a reaccionar como que
tenemos que reaccionar ya
por eso compuso la canción de los monos
porque son ellos que nos darán a
nosotros si nos dicen oye que lo que
está pasando porque están cortando los
árboles donde vivimos nosotros si
nosotros estamos a cada rato
ramón chicharrón le deseamos mucha
suerte con este nuevo ep del sonido que
usted trae aquí en montreal desde
colombia desde costa rica muchas gracias
[Música]